wonder maxum off has a long weird
history in the world of marvel comics
and now that she's finally getting some
real attention in the mcu
there's no better time to bone up on her
story this is the untold truth of the
scarlet witch
wandering pietro maximov's first origin
story painted them as nameless wandering
orphans
rescued by the mutant magneto who soon
becomes their surrogate father
things get complicated however when
captain america's old war buddy
robert frank also known as whizzer comes
into the mix
it turns out that robert and his wife
madeline had once been exposed to huge
amounts of radiation
as a result their first child nuklo was
born a radioactive mutant
when maddie got pregnant again they
visited a super scientist called the
high evolutionary for help
maddie and her child died during the
birth but the evolutionary did manage to
deliver wonder and pietro into robert's
arms
however robert was too grief-stricken to
raise them and
fled since he's a speedster and maddie
was a powerful redhead
it makes sense that there'd be wonder
and pietro's real parents
right wrong a romani puppeteer named
django maximoff subsequently claims
fatherhood of the twins
and to prove his love he imprisons their
spirits and magical puppets
obviously you didn't see that coming
in the end django does sacrifice his
life for the twins but it's then
revealed that their real mother was a
woman named magda
and that their real father is magneto
eventually even magneto is revealed as a
fake
and currently the twins real mother is
said to be natalya maximoff the sister
of django who was just one in a long
line of scarlet witches but as for their
real father
well for now nobody really knows during
gerolia's appearance in the marvel
universe
wanda feels like she owes magneto her
life for saving her from a mutant-hating
mom
and this is why she agrees to serve him
her judifor brother has no love for
magneto however
and only joins with the evil mutant to
protect her nonetheless this begins
their tenure and perhaps the most
dysfunctional super villain team
of all time the brotherhood of evil
mutants in their first battle against
the x-men
magneto goes big setting up a bomb
capable of destroying
an entire country however quicksilver
disarms it
not wanting innocence to die during
their second battle on asteroid m
wander hexes a control panel to stop
magneto from blasting the x-men out the
airlock
during their next fight wonder defies
magneto's orders to save her brother
from accidentally being hit by a deadly
magnetic weapon
as a result magneto abandons them both
though he does pick them up later
the last draw comes when piedro is
almost killed during yet another battle
against the x-men causing wonder and
pietro to leave the brotherhood for good
soon after they applied to join the
avengers and are welcomed onto the team
by captain america
early on in wonders time with the
avengers the synthezoid known as
the vision joins the team wonder always
has like the strong silent type and
against all lads the two slowly begin to
fall in love
not everyone is pleased with this
development however quicksilver views
the vision as an abomination and worthy
of his sister's love
hawkeye having just broken up with black
widow but sues wander with official
intensity
even though she isn't interested
unbeknownst to them all however
that being known as a mortise is subtly
pushing the pair together
immortals fears that wonder could
potentially have incredibly powerful and
dangerous children
and believes that if she is with a
symphoid-like vision
she will never give birth after one of
the avengers many battles
vision reaches out to wander offering to
be there for her as she looks for pietro
who has gone missing marking the true
beginning of their long and complex love
affair
i do do you
[Music]
yes i do one of the avengers greatest
foes is ultron
a murderous robot with something of an
oedipus complex
in one storyline from the 1970s ultron
uses the brain patterns of his sort of
mother janet pym
to create his bride jocasta and just to
make things weirder he also
uses mind control to force his so-called
father hank pym
to help him when ultron subsequently
attacks the avengers
he has to deal with one hero he hasn't
met before the scarlet witch and she
turns out to be a pretty tough opponent
as it happens ultron constructed himself
out of adamantium an ion unbreakable
metal
but to do this he had to use an internal
molecular rearranger
which is the only thing that can alter
adamantium while it's being set
during their confrontation scarlet wedge
hits him with a hex that momentarily
causes the device to malfunction but
captain america gets in the way before
she can finish him off
and ultron nearly kills them both
jocasta is eventually called to her
husband
and the avengers follow her to a convent
of all places
a trap is set for wonder but she
survives and causes a molecular
rearranger to malfunction so badly
that the energy in ultron's armor
combusts and explodes
luckily thor manages to absorb it in
time but ultron isn't done with wonder
just yet
it's soon revealed that ultron used
hypnosis to force tony stark to
reconstruct him
in the event of his destruction as part
of this plan
he also a stark kidnapped wonder luckily
as ever things turn out pretty much okay
following the dissolution of the west
coast avengers in the 1990s iron man
recruits us agents
spider woman wonder man and the scarlet
witch to form a new edgier team
one that will take a more proactive
approach to super heroics
based on an ultra high-tech compound
called the works stark is particularly
keen to get wanda on board because she
can interact with the chaos computer
using her probability powers to predict
problems before they actually arise
however things fall apart quickly for
the team
known as force works when the man is
disintegrated by the cree on their first
mission
and while the scarlet witch is made team
leader by stark
he frequently undermines her as he
becomes more and more unstable
as it turns out stark is being driven
insane by a mortise who is disguised as
his past self
kang the conqueror under the
supervillain's control stark ends up
killing several people
and injuring others in addition to
introducing the evil cybermancer to the
team
in the end other than a few adventures
here and there wanda never gets to prove
herself as a true team leader
force works is then dissolved after iron
man's untimely demise
when the vision and the scarlet witch
are captured by the witches of new salem
and about to be sacrificed
the vision escapes and quickly defeats
their leader vertigo
one that channels her powerful magic to
defeat the witches
and surrounded by the vision's love
makes a little wish
thanks to her probability altering
powers she becomes pregnant
in time her beloved twin sons william
and thomas are born for a while
all seems well until the twins start
disappearing whenever wonder isn't near
them
turns out they may be lost soul shouts
of the actor turned demon master
pandemonium
he takes the boys away and grotesquely
joins them with his flesh
replacing his lost arms with their
bodies which obviously goes down pretty
badly but even this origin
isn't quite true which is made clear
when mephisto pops up and claims that
the boys are really parts of his
soul lost when he was temporarily
destroyed by franklin richards
agatha harkness then casts a spell to
make wonder forget about her children
a decision that has devastating
consequences for the entire marvel
universe
later a group of young heroes forms a
team known as the young avengers
they include billy wicken kaplan an
avengers fanboy who has supernatural
abilities
looking for new members they bust tommy
speed shepard out of prison
who happens to look a heck of a lot like
billy later when they run into the
scarlet witch
it's revealed that wicked and speed are
in fact reincarnations of wonder's
children's souls
when the whisper makes a flipping
comment about wanda's lost children
she realizes her memories have been
erased suffers a nervous breakdown and
kills several avengers
including the vision hoping to end her
rampage dr strange uses the eye of
agamotto
and shows her a memory too terrible for
her to comprehend
as a result wonder goes catatonic
magneto then takes her to his country of
genocia
hoping professor x will be able to help
her unfortunately he can't
and to make matters worse by this point
the x-men and avengers have begun to
debate whether or not
they should kill her this doesn't sit
well with quicksilver
who begs magneto for help and then takes
matas into his own hands
convincing his sister to make a new
world one where they can be truly happy
suddenly everyone is living in a world
where mutants are the dominant species
magneto and his family are international
superstars
wander is supposedly human and every
hero has everything they've always
wished for
peter parker is married to gwen stacy
and uncle ben is still alive
kitty pride is a teacher wolverine is
head of shield
and remembers everything from his
previous life over time the heroes
slowly regain their memories and
believing he's responsible for this
take the battle to magneto during the
battle a fragile wonder falls apart
and infamously declares no more mutants
as a result
roughly 90 percent of the world's mutant
population suddenly lose their powers
with many dying in the process later
this event becomes known as
m day beyond wonders long marriage to
the vision there's been no shortage of
men with a romantic interest in her
sometimes she feels the same way but
when she doesn't she's usually more than
happy to put them in their place
so who exactly has had their eye on
wonder well there's the mutant angel
who jokes that he's ready to fill out an
evil mutant application
the first time they encounter each other
wonder and name mortar submariner share
a mutual attraction when they first meet
but neymar realizes that he is still
heartbroken over sue storm
later when wonder joins the avengers
hawkeye hits on her for years but
no avail extra dimensional warrior
archon also nurses an unrequited
interest in her
wonder is even interested in captain
america at one point in time which he
reciprocates but nothing ever really
comes of it
things get a little weirder when it
comes to simon williams also known as
wonder man
this is because ultron used simon's
brain to create the vision
wonders most significant love interest
at one point wonder is actually able to
bring simon back to life because of the
love between them
after which the two start up their own
relationship strangest of all however
wonder briefly falls in love with dr
doom they're even engaged for a while
until doom steals all her powers that is
in the beginning
wonder believes herself to be a mutant
and her powers to be hexes which bring
bad luck to her opponents
case in point in one of her first
battles against the x-men
she points to a roof above angel and
this subsequently falls on him
of course it is later revealed that
wonder is not a mutant at all
instead the high evolutionary
experimented on her in a way that wound
up making her capable
of manipulating magic for her romance
the demon catholic later gave her power
over chaos magic 2
and she is also a nexus being making her
uniquely attuned to certain types of
magical power
there's nothing more horrifying
than a miracle
[Music]
the upshot of all this experimentation
and magical mayhem
wonder is pretty much unbeatable most of
the time her powers are limited to
causing walls to collapse
or blasting her foes with energy if
she's imbued with enough power however
she's more than capable of completely
remaking the universe
as well as this wonder has shown the
ability to heal manipulate time
read minds absorb massive amounts of
energy fly
and even occasionally raise the dead
basically she can do anything a story
might require
which means the sky's the limit for the
powers of the scarlet witch
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one